[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i'm bob isis of isis toyota
and we have a great collection of
pre-owned certified toyotas but there's
one thing i want to make very clear and
it's that we have nothing to do with the
terrorists over there in the middle east
right now and that's why we are the good
isis
all right listen you gotta lean into the
isis thing it's a good marketing tool
it's a great marketing tool i agree with
barbie i think you should be like here
at isis toyota will behead the
competition yes no we're not doing this
what are you guys talking about we're
not wishing death to any of our enemies
we are wishing death too low to high
prices me and barbie we can hold ak-47s
yeah
no no that would be so cool so i'm
holding an ak-47 she's holding ak-47
you're like we're going to buzz toyotas
and i could be i can be doing that like
terrorist turkey gobble thing you know i
mean we're like
at isis toyota we have nothing to do
with abu bakar al-baghdadi and his
vicious gang of thugs all we're trying
to do is put you into an affordable
pre-owned certified toyota today is
monday september 5th and gillian keeves
is coming out with a brand new season
later this month shane gillis is on the
joe rogan experience thursday during a
protect our parks episode with mark
norman and ari shafir where he announced
that gillian keeves his sketch show is
coming out with a new season later this
month and it'll be available on
gilliankeeves.tv
take that snl
you silly [ __ ] and welcome back to
the joke world comedy update every
single monday bringing you the comedy
news that you need to know from your
favorite comedians your favorite podcast
whether it be new specials new shows
releasing like this one or new guest
appearances on each other's pods that
you don't want to miss all the best
information in the comedy world in one
place so please consider subscribing in
joke world right now turning on the post
notifications so you don't miss anything
and downloading this episode on spotify
to support the channel i'm losing money
on half these things cause you and your
punk ass kids come down to [ __ ] with our
[ __ ] you want an ak-47 stop [ __ ] with
our toyotas come down and buy them like
a man
i'm
i'm under a lot of [ __ ] stress i'll
go [ __ ] nuts we are closed on 9 11.
if your dad was real isis you'd be up in
heaven right now covered in virgins but
instead you're a fat [ __ ] virgin
covered in used toyotas yeah okay so i'd
like what are you [ __ ] ripping the
[ __ ] out come down to isis toyota or
i'll [ __ ] kill myself and everybody
here so according to what shane said on
the joe rogan experience season two is
set to premiere this september september
2022 and probably later september he
didn't give an exact date but it will
air off of their website gillian keeves
dot tv most likely so i went to check
out this website see what's all about
see if they're gonna make you pay for
season two all they asked me for is my
email and then i got to watch whatever
was on their website so i don't think
that this is going to cost any money but
even if they did personally i'm more
than willing to chip in a few bucks so
they don't have to do this on a network
so they can do it by themselves you know
have full creative freedom over the
process of these sketches all their
jokes stay in i'm okay with paying for
top tier comedy in today's day and age
so i'll definitely be checking out
season two paywall or not leading up to
the release of season two they've been
posting on their youtube account season
one bloopers of gillian keeves and those
are hilarious i think it's up to four
parts out right now and they also
premiered the whole season on august
19th in a theater in philadelphia so a
few people have seen these sketches if
you're one of them let me know how they
are i'm pretty excited
look
bob you need to get over your dead wife
get yourself a gold chain and the [ __ ]
just comes running dude you brought me
over here in the middle of this talk to
me about getting [ __ ]
you want to drag me away from something
like this to talk to me about getting
[ __ ] right now no i brought you over
here talking about isis and then [ __ ]
came up
you drugged me away from this talk to me
about [ __ ] yeah
i'm sorry yeah that's why you drove me
away from this talk about getting [ __ ]
right now
did you two drug me over here to talk
about getting [ __ ] right now i took it
over
it's also been said that they're
improving the production for season two
as well as hiring recognizable talent
john mcever is the writer behind most of
the season 1 sketches with cameos from
many comedians like h foley matt
mccuster mike rainey and more season one
has many hilarious moments like the dads
only fans and the trump speed dating so
i have high high high expectations for
season two i'll be checking out pay wall
or not on gillian keeves dot tv then the
uncles participate in a variety of
activities that suit their skill set
okay uncle tommy
yeah how old are these girls
are any of them underage
well you can do this
i know
okay
go ahead
they're all beautiful angels
right but are any of them underage
i don't know
so
i have to assume
they're all they're all underage oh
great
jobs
yes i'm so proud of you yes i'm proud of
myself remember guys
as developed as they may seem
it doesn't mean they're 18.
just my computer
did you guys get this laptop some
exciting news for all the tuesdays out
there we had a brand new comedy podcast
hit the scene last week from the
producer of tuesday's with stories chuck
staton and his friends brad ruher and
ray harrington comes funbearable a brand
new comedy podcast between these three
guys coming out every week moving
forward this woman who was a fan from
way back like when i was like i'm just
starting to feature right that guy uh
she wanted to come to the show she had
previously been banned
before activity outside of that uh she
showed up and uh becky the wonderful
bartender
the best uh she was like hey so
she came
and uh she wanted to give you a cake oh
boy for your birthday that's nice all
right all right and she was saying she
wanted to surprise you with it on stage
no no i don't want that at all and she's
like okay and this woman tried so many
times to like sneak
up to her seat with the cake wow and
eventually becky was like we're gonna
hold the cake cut to the end of the show
she comes into the green room she hands
me the cake
the cake says on top in icing happy
birthday
n-word
ray
did you think she had it made at a
bakery she did have made it a bakery
not a bakery bakery a grocery store
bakery right and she she told me the
story of how she had to fight with the
person to have them make it
but here's the deal it didn't say
my n-word ray yeah it just said happy
birthday n-word race
a picture of it a little i do not have
it
we need that photo
just a little huckleberry finn energy
there
mark twain insane not in quotes nope
nothing just that wow the weird part is
as soon as i looked at this cake i was
baffled i was just like
kind of a good way to have a diet you
know like
three yeah of the cake yeah but then
wait now i'm leaving this i should eat
it first she should eat
the er
there you go is there any reason that
you can think of that she put that on
the cake
and they
let's treat this like a safe space did
you have an ironic stage name that
you're
yes were you in the chitlin circuit
before this it was when i had a
catchphrase
happy birthday it just happened to be
your birthday
mark norman appeared on episode one
which is out right now and they've
already some future guests some great
comedians such as joe list and kevin
ryan so be sure to check out fun
bearable on youtube right now subscribe
to their channel watch our podcast we're
definitely going to continue to report
on it moving forward definitely a show
with a lot of potential now i gotta take
a second to talk to you about the
sponsor of this video our friends at the
freeze pipe whether it be a handheld
beast like this one or one of their
monster bongs freeze pipe just hits
different and that's because it's built
different the freeze pipes uses glycerin
a non-toxic gel that freezes quicker
than water and stays frozen much longer
the glycogen chambers are designed to
improve how much and how long your smoke
is chilled for so you put the pipe in
the freezer this part gets completely
frozen you put in for an hour this
part's completely frozen then when you
pull smoke out it goes around these
coils so by the time that the smoke hits
your mouth it feels like winter dude you
don't even know that you're smoking this
it's so smooth shipping is always free
and comes in discreet packaging this is
honestly one of the smaller items that
they have but still has a good amount of
weight to it thick glass and packs a
very heavy punch i like it for the ad
read because i get to like point and
talk and use it like a gavel but check
out their website they have things way
bigger than this way more complex things
that would blow your mind if you're
curious at all just click the link in
the description go check out their
website just for fun they have something
for everything at the freezepipe.com and
use code joke 10 for 10 off your order
joke 10 support the channel support
freeze pipe back to the video guest
spots from last week your mom's house
did not have a guest two bears one cave
was burt and tom tom and bert tiger
belly also did not have a guest it was
just bobby and kalila whiskey ginger
talked to sam morrell this past weekend
with theovan had on nick schwartzen the
joe rogan experienced last week how to
protect our parks episode air on
thursday which if we're all being honest
is the best quality podcast comedy
content available right now that group
is just kills it every single time and
then he also did a fight companion with
brian callan eddie bravo and brendan
schaub
the flagrant podcast had on russell
brand which is a very enjoyable episode
we might be drunk talk to tom papa and
then kill tony tonight is the great and
powerful joe rogan we have two new
specials that came out last week number
one is a youtube special from brian
cowan called man tears i was surprised
to see it i didn't hear about it coming
out before but i did watch it and it was
enjoyable it was definitely a brian
cowan humor special so if you're a fan
of callan you're definitely going to be
a fan of this special and then sam
morrell same time tomorrow came out on
netflix last week we did a video about
that last monday and we're also going to
do a video reacting to your guys's
thoughts about the special so go check
out our community section where we
posted thoughts about the special
type whatever you want in there and then
some of the comments will be featured on
a video moving forward but that's it for
the joke world economy update this week
thank you so much for watching as always
make sure to subscribe and like and do
all the you know dumb youtube stuff just
to help us out here at joke world thank
you for being a part of the brand and
part of the community also everyone
who's followed us on instagram and dm
for the free stickers those will be
coming out to you in no time we got kind
of backed up there a lot of demand which
is sick thank you guys for following us
on instagram we're really trying to
build that thing up and thanks for
getting these free stickers stick them
all around the town dude support the
brand joke world to the moon thank you
again they're coming soon i didn't
forget about you and if you want some
you can still sign up dm us joke world
on instagram
enough of me
goodbye
[Music]
you